what we're going to do in this video is
explore the relationship between local
linearity at a point and
differentiability at a point so local
linearity is this idea that if we zoom
in sufficiently on a point that even a
nonlinear function that is
differentiable at that point will
actually look linear so let me show some
examples of that so let's say we had Y
is equal to x squared so that's that
there clearly a nonlinear function but
we can zoom in on a point and resume
sufficiently in we will see that it
looks roughly linear so let's say we
want to zoom in on the point 1 comma 1
so let's do that so zooming in on the
point 1 comma 1 already it is looking
roughly linear at that point and this
property of local linearity is very
helpful when trying to approximate a
function around a point so for example
we can figure out we could take the
derivative at the point 1 1 use that as
the slope of our tangent line find the
equation of the tangent line and use
that equation to a plot to approximate
values of our function around x equals 1
and you might not need to do that for y
is equal to x squared but it could
actually be very very useful for a more
complex function but the big takeaway
here at the point 1 1 it is displaying
this idea of local linearity and it is
also differentiable at that point now
let's look at another example of a point
on a function where we aren't
differentiable and we also don't see the
local linearity so for example let's do
the absolute value of x and let me shift
it over a little bit just so that we
don't overlap is what much all right so
the absolute value of X minus 1 it
actually is differentiable as long as
we're not at this corner right over here
as long as we're not at the point 1
comma 0 for any other x value it is
differentiable but right at
equals one we've talked in other videos
how we aren't differentiable there and
then we can use this local linearity
idea to test it as well
and once again this is not rigorous
mathematics but it is to give you an
intuition no matter how far we zoom in
we still see this sharp corner it would
be hard to construct the only tangent
line a unique line that goes through
this point 1 comma 0 I can construct an
actual infinite number of lines that go
through 1 comma 0 but that do not go
through the rest of the curve and so
they'll notice wherever you see a hard
corner like we're seeing it 1 comma 0 in
this absolute value function that's a
pretty good indication that we are not
going to be differentiable at that point
now let's zoom out a little bit and
let's take another function let's take a
function where the differentiability or
the lack of differentiability is not
because of a corner but it's because as
we zoom in it starts to look linear but
it starts to look like a vertical line
so a good example of that would be
square root let's say 4 minus x squared
so that's the top half of a circle of
radius 2 and let's focus on the point 2
comma zero because right over there we
actually are not differentiable and if
we zoom in far enough we see right at 2
comma zero that we are approaching what
looks like a vertical line
so once again we would not be
differentiable at two comma zero now
another thing I want to point out all of
these you really didn't have to zoom in
too much to appreciate that hey I got a
corner here on this absolute value
function or a two comma zero or at
negative two comma zero something a
little bit stranger than normal is
happening there so maybe I'm not
differentiable but there are some
functions that we don't see as typically
in a algebra precalculus or calculus
class but it can look like a hard corner
from a zoomed out perspective but as we
zoom in once again we'll see the local
linearity and they are also
differentiable at those points so a good
example of that let me to get rid of
some of these just so we can really zoom
in let's say Y is equal to X to the and
I'm going to make a very large exponent
here so X to the 10th power it's
starting to look a little bit like a
corner there let's make it to the
hundredth power
well now it's looking even more like a
corner there let me go to the thousandth
power just for good measure so this
scale it looks like we have a corner at
the point one comma zero now this curve
actually does not go to the point one
comma zero if X is 1 then Y is going to
be 1 and we'll see that as we zoom in
this what looks like a hard corner is
going to soften and that's good because
this function is actually differentiable
at every value of x it's a little bit
more exotic than what we typically see
but as we zoom in we'll actually see
that let's just zoom in on what looks
like a fairly hard corner but if we zoom
sufficiently enough even at the part
that looks like the hardest part of the
corner the real corner will see that it
starts to soften and it curves and if we
zoom in sufficiently it will actually
look like a line hard to believe when
you're really zoomed out and I'm going
at the point that really looked like a
corner from a distance but as we zoom
out in we see once again this local
linearity and it's a non vertical line
and so once again it's destroyed any
point on this curve that we are going to
be differentiable so the whole point
here is sometimes you might have to zoom
in a
lot a tool like desmos which I'm using
right now is very helpful for doing that
and this isn't rigorous mathematics but
to give you an intuitive sense that if
you zoom in sufficiently and you start
to see curve looking more and more like
a line good indication that you are
differentiable if you keep zooming in it
still looks like a hard corner or if you
zoom in it looks like the tangent might
be vertical well then some questions
should arise in your brain